let's talk about the gay gun-carrying
man with a mullet oh yeah handlebar
mustache and a big old cat on his lap
we're gonna watch him watch mojo top 10
worst things done by the cast of tiger
king waiting to talk about tiger king
john has apparently finished it I don't
know when but waiting for the word
finally told me I was like what the f
let's finally do a video about tiger
cake do these people make for
entertaining television absolutely but
there aren't many heroes in this story
welcome to watchmojo.com worst things
done by the cast of tiger king for this
list we're looking at the most
deplorable actions of the people in the
Netflix original dossiers tiger King
where do you want to start look crazy
beginning I'll be taking into account
things we saw play out on-screen actions
discussed on camera and things that the
cast members are alleged or rumored to
have done
please note since many of these are
shocking twists and revelations from the
series uh spoiler alert is now in effect
never be weird to get a spoiler alert
from Tigers but there's nothing he loves
more than being the center of attention
good press or bad press he embraces the
spotlight so sure enough seemingly mere
moments after one of his employees has
their arm ripped off by a tiger he's
addressing Park gets money back but it
was far from the most pressing issue the
fact that Jo voices concern on camera no
less about how this will impact it point
it shows just how messed up his
priorities are and it's really easy to
do that Eric and you know this because I
work with a man that also has no legs
never not had Jeff Lowe stealing the zoo
at the end of Tiger Kings fourth episode
Jeph Loeb rides in from out of nowhere
Joe's tailor-made personal Savior
watches too much sons of anarchy
seen sometime in 2015 he just bought the
persona that he was gonna save the zoo
so we dubbed him the Godfather motivated
by his financially draining legal battle
with Carole Baskin Joe ops to transfer
the zoo into Jeff named Jeff Lewis still
the zoo
Jeff lo stole of a zoo but it's pretty
clear to all that well Jeff has become a
partner in the zoo the ownership is in
name only after accusing Jo of having
committed fraud Jeff exercises his right
as the legal owner of the property by
claiming it for himself and kicking joel
exotic out just gone Jose no saint but
that doesn't justify Jeff's opportunism
never ate Jill recycling old Walmart God
knows he serves that to the big cats are
already living in an environment so
fundamentally different from their own
diets becomes especially important at
respected and accredited zoos and animal
sanctuaries tigers and other big cats
are typically fed fresh ground beef as
well as a carefully balanced selection
of supplements to make sure they get all
necessary nutrients at GW zoo they get
some meat from livestock but it's
heavily supplemented with expired meat
including processed varieties from
Walmart dumpsters
we're the world's worst about gonna
cheat Walmart Chuck you know surrender
is you needs to go with the cats but
get him some demons if that isn't bad
enough that's being consumed by the use
in the pizza Joe started serving to park
number seven
Jill remarrying so quickly after the
death of his husband Travis oh my gosh
not only does it cover Joe's political
aspirations it also gives us a close
look at the life of Joseph in Travis who
accidentally killed himself
Sharon was gonna make shuttin it that
way I mean you had to come with almost
everyone face did you Travis dying was
shocking that photo just really shocked
me yeah so cringing yes so crazy goes
whatever he does felt so bad burn mmm
acting there after hosting a painfully
awkward funeral for Travis that felt far
more focused on Joe than his dearly
departed husband the zoo owner proceeds
to meet and marry another man decades
younger than him and he does it all
within the span of two months adding
insult to injury
Joe invited her and according to her
never spoke to her again no it was the
cameraman me and then I didn't hear
anything from them again
number six Carol's treatment of
volunteers and interns were first
introduced to tiger Kings colorful cast
of characters Carol Baskin definitely
comes across as the most ethically
minded as early as Episode two however
the whoa yeah self says she doesn't pay
people to care for the cats because
she's got all the free labor she could
want I don't pay anybody to do animal
care because people will do that for
free
volunteers are organized into a
hierarchy recognizable by t-shirt color
we be taking a year or more to
to another level an internship can
fast-track the process but it can
involve working six days a week and
putting in 12-hour days sure the
sanctuary is non profit but Baskins
critics have accused her of taking
advantage five and it's like I've seen
you around here a lot number five Doc's
treatment of his wives doctor and oh
yeah his four five wives to me he's to
me doc is a scariest one dogs scariest
one amazing onyx dynamic with his
partners is certainly his dog actually
seems fire king it seems that he has a
pattern of taking on attractive young
apprentices and working them to the bone
for an extra no pay considering the
emotional and psychological manipulation
just notice the tiger doll on the back
door yeah seems to cultivate many online
have labeled it grooming you controlled
every aspect of our day but also they
were pushing me to get implants there's
have gone so far as to call it a cult
promise yet been here 35 years heard it
all forever
to hear it from one of a few women who
actually left it certainly sounds like
one never for aging we should go spire
yeah we are admittedly getting into
speculation it can't be said for sure
who exactly was responsible for starting
the fire that claimed Joe sue deity of
illumination we can get a pretty good
idea
those big Kirkham arguably lost warned
that fire than anyone else so he seems
an unlikely culprit it was like that's
why retirement that just
everything invested in that he burned
down many people who are strongly
opposed to animal parks like Joe's his
detractor was going to such extreme
lengths seem similarly far-fetched then
that conversation Joe in his attorney
let's be honest its Joe all the motive
in the world
Joe would kill his animals it's horrible
but it is certainly one possible it's
definitely possible
I have no first-hand knowledge that I
can't prove it number three animal
neglect if you talk to the who have
escaped some of these situations what
they'll say is that they were treated so
abusively but not only are they abusing
the people there's a lot that happens in
Tiger King that feels open to
interpretation or could benefit from
further unreliable narrator is the
widespread and mistreatment of animals
sure Joe has affection for his pet cats
but they're not being taken care of
properly the dumpster meat has got
enough but as we see in the series yes
the wall marks were still findings from
a 2011 investigation have come to light
documenting Joe and his staff regularly
being physically abusive with the
animals in the wake of his conviction
and releases a series even Joe exotic
himself has gone on record saying that
he's ashamed of how the animals were
treated i truly believe
Joe started a zoo for the purposes of
good reasons the state needs to pass
laws this breeding has got to stop
number two murder plot honestly this
time series simply focused on Joe exotic
in a zoo we still would have been
absolutely fascinated but adding to the
surreal nature of the show is the fact
that on top of everything else it
includes a real-life murder for hire
plot
professional and personal rivalries are
common in many industries but rarely are
they allowed to escalate to the point of
murderous intent in detail if this were
anyone else we dismiss these accusations
as outlandish considering the countless
threats the Joe exotic made against
Carroll Baskin it's not hard to wrap
your mind around him hiring a man to
killer
[Music]
there is no justified such a horrific
Bronco we continue be sure to subscribe
to our Channel and bring the belt again
I don't think ten is another they're
gonna be runners on your own make sure
you go into your settings and switch on
you do a top 10 per episode oh she
totally did it yeah the second that was
a third episode the second it started
like 10 minutes and it like a hundred
percent I don't need the physical
evidence especially with the will yeah
angry and now she threatened to kill me
Carol and I got into a big bust and she
ordered me out of the house or she would
kill me and if Lewis was indeed killed
as many suspects including his family
well then that would certainly warrant
the number one spot isn't it suspicious
that the pub the disappearance yeah
[Laughter]
succeeding in ending someone's life even
that Lewis haven't been seen in 20 years
who knows maybe Joe's music video isn't
entirely inaccurate for what it's worth
Oh Jay Simpson is Tiger sashimi right
now I'm just saying I would know gosh no
Jason they're like damn if I had a tiger
Carol totally did it
all right I know there's people being
like we need the physical evidence yeah
there's enough to conclude all that
footage of watching her oh man the thing
I'm always saying this documentary could
have been called horrible people as the
documentary just keeps progressing very
evident like no one here seems like
they're a kook even the characters are
not only not even characters these
people seem larger than life but there
are people who I'm like okay so I guess
Carol's the protagonist like women in
the first episode and then as he
progresses really we should do that's
exactly so different than you know
exactly
this has got a different structure yeah
yeah had worker I grew to like him just
because he was like straight shooter and
he seemed like he really did care about
the animals through and through but
there's like there's still a low
standard and I think that's a big issue
here because and I do agree somewhat
with the criticism that of all the
things this has brought to light one of
the least talked about things is the
treatment of the animals that's a major
criticism I had for it but I think that
is you know in terms of producing
marketing storytelling stuff it's it's
the least engaging part perhaps for not
all audiences like that was the main
reason I wanted to watch it and as of
course it gets hooked you get so focused
on the people it's like bookended
primarily with the treatment of the end
yeah
first episode focuses on it and like the
last ten minutes I'm like playing with
the cat but I think that was a part of
the documentaries point all this
happened and the last thing people were
really focused on was the was the end
yes that's true and that was a big
message the movie was trying to convey
about this whole scenario of course they
got all this but I can only describe as
like a producer's golden ticket yes you
don't even have to structure this thing
when I'm watching this documentary I was
surprised by how far backward going with
such great quality looking cam because I
didn't know anything about Tiger King
much as I poked fun of the idea that
there was WatchMojo video presents a
spoiler alert at the top I found myself
like by episode 3 going I don't want to
read or hear anything about it because I
don't know have this I don't know the
story and I don't wanna know how this
end so I did find myself like avoiding
spoilers on the internet tales so rarely
do you have something in real life to do
that we talked about this at our podcast
on patreon about documentaries have
evolved so much from when we were kids
because they are wildly entertaining
before they a lot of them used to just
feel like educational material the way
they edit them now and vent TV they are
a vent TV they're there while they're
just like any great television and the
fact that they structure is such a
wonderful narrative behind it like the
creative heads on how they compose this
documentary I know the main thing that
we should be talking about of course is
the actual stuff in the documentary but
I do god I want to shout out like
the editors involved how they took years
and years of footage to compose this
really compelling and engaging narrative
that the world is talking about you know
cuz that's a hard thing to put together
I can't imagine like where do you begin
and how do you structure this and where
do you who do you focus on primarily per
episode how are you gonna let this story
unravel and I think from a news where to
lay revelations exactly I think from a
storytelling perspective even though
it's it's more taking you know
interviews and facts and information and
turning that into a narrative that's a
very hard thing to do and kudos to all
people and Walter do this because now
this is like I don't know about
worldwide but certainly a nationwide hit
yeah you know and I mean you think of
movies having deleted scenes but for
something like this I mean you've got
hours upon years of footage footage like
it's just deleted every yeah it's years
of footage it is not included so I'm
sure they have tons more that we can
look at the one guy who I thought was
like one of the only reasonably
level-headed people here was the
campaign manager for when Joe is running
for governor or president than governor
like he was just funny to me he's very
matter of how blunt he was about how
terrible it is Travis died that scene
was probably the most shocking moments
to me yeah especially they're looking at
that footage there and then yeah there's
the part which I thought was so strange
watching his documentary the guy who did
not seem as crazy as the other people
yet he had the craziest criminal
conviction history da cantle no not da
cantle yeah I do want to talk about the
guy who inspired Scarface supposedly oh
yeah why didn't any help like this guy
seems nuts when you first hear about him
that he's are hanging out in or same in
the other guys but da kantola
to me he was the scariest one like he's
the one you they had the hardest time
exposing true things here the whole
thing with the cult and the woman of
course is a very unsettling and eerie
but believable yeah absolutely
believable he seems like the most
sociopathically functional he seems like
he could blend in and he seemed like he
could be clever yeah whereas I think a
lot of the different aspects of this
show have to do with these people's a
but be incompetence because even the
people who care and that's part of the
problem is like even the people who do
care and are kind of all rice don't have
the level of knowledge and expertise
with this stuff and so like he does
maybe have some of that but also a whole
lot of other really dubious stuff he
seems like he's the best at covering up
they have footage where he's going on
like Jay Leno or something like that and
saves a pretty spirit station riggers
that guy seems like the smartest one of
them all he knows how to run his
business he knows how to keep secrets he
knows how to present himself he knows
how to be outspoken and oh and argue
back like there are clearly moments
where this dude is insane narcissistic
personality compare him to someone like
Joe exotic Jeff Lowe presented himself
as someone kind of normal but then as
his past starts unraveling more his
head'll of that whole story like how him
and his wife being swingers go to Vegas
similar woman with baby tiger and he's
picking his housekeeper and he's like
he's totally out for his own like
self-image it wants to be the coolest
people have asked tribuna like I don't
know how that could possibly review this
series in like even an hour yeah so
we'll have to do is react to some more
videos and then occasionally bring up
other bits of information we haven't
brought it before together supercut of
all the discussions and Kalb at the
review because there's so much
mind-blowing stuff and i mean if a lot
of it would just be us going this is
crazy and that's it yeah this is larger
than life and I can't believe the guy
who actually was hired to go do the hit
on Carroll Baskin and then just kind of
deciding to not to I think it was really
fast say about the exposure of all this
there's all the times when you're
looking at these people through the lens
of a camera it can be easy to kind of
just go these people are nuts why would
you ever trust these guys why would you
ever do it I thought the documentary did
a really good job at going so in-depth
that even with Joe exotic you can see
that with the right kind of person for
him to attract he could easily
manipulate this person and it's the same
way with all and right down to dock with
with the women and Joe Tzadik with the
people who were struggling in
lower-class
right off the bus kind of a kind of
individuals Carol Baskin leading off
people who care about the yeah my real
it is so fascinating to see like the
Carroll
skin character keep on characters but
the Carol Baskin personality her and Joe
work are very similar what they do it's
just the president it's funny how
presentation and mission statement and
all those things can wort the perception
that people who volunteer work there or
attend as customers will not latch on to
the horrible nature of what's going on
yeah especially in places like these
were again these types of reservations
are kind of isolating they're on their
own level of regulation and the level of
just above board you know it's like even
as a guest it's kind of got to be
impossible to tell if you're going to
someplace that's actually reputable in
any way shape or form or even have the
resources to be kind of concerned with
that I've never been to like one of
these kinds of zoos before last time I
went to the zoo is LA Zoo I remembered
it really hit me hard when I was there
of how just that just a regular zoo now
what if he's like exotic petting zoos
exotic someone's backyard
it hit me very hard just how horrible of
living conditions it must be for these
animals I talked a lot about on the
livestream that we did recently I feel
like the last year learning and more
MORE about animals and then about a
month ago after diving deep into some
animal abuse documentaries it hit me
when I was driving past a chick-fil-a
like I just can't have meat anymore I
can't do it so I have been like greatly
impacted and like I said when I started
this documentary I was more interested
in that side of things
regular zoos even to me are disturbing
like those animals just seem so unhappy
I would grow up thinking like other
bored they don't want to come out they
have this interesting thing in here that
that produced the one who was originally
produced in the reality show for Joey
Tzadik he was talking about there's this
weird power and then you know Jeff Lowe
uses the the Tigers tooth or women
there's this weird power that comes with
holding an exotic animal or petting zoo
animal and I've never done that and then
the closest thing I've had to witnessing
such a thing as being at is the LA Zoo
feeling it's so sad for these animals
you're just look so depressed but then
also simultaneously being amongst the
crowd going I want to take a look at the
tiger yeah you know and I just made me
feel like [ __ ] you been - that's a
sliver of a degree it compared to
actually going to an exotic zoo I can't
imagine
like how easy it would be to manipulate
people with exotic animals which in turn
is abusing the animals and you know
themselves
oh yeah cuz it's not about they're more
their well-being anywhere they're just
objects for you and that's the thing
that really depressed me by the end of
it cuz when they show that little Kota
footage of Joe when he's much younger
with that little cub or whatever and
it's a film it's got music and a
monologue over it so it's been it's
meant to make you think this but it
didn't really seem like yeah this
probably started off earnestly enough in
a place that was about hey I love these
animals I'm passionate about them and I
want to I want to be the one to give
them a good life and I don't know if
this is a stretch but you know like yeah
the big cat especially I have to imagine
has some kind of rush to be the one
who's you know taming and communicating
with them like you even think back to
like the old circus when the main
attractions was the lion tamer you know
and so it's got to give you a power
boost to be you know like a big cat
Wrangler of any kind in the wrong hands
of the wrong people you see how it
totally just goes into accessorizing
clothes come in and then pretty soon
yeah it doesn't seem like anybody cares
actually about the whole point of doing
this and it's disgusting it makes you
think too about even interact with your
own pets and stuff like that because in
a tan gentle way there are ways in which
we do accessorize animals even in
innocuous ways even though those aren't
as grim as this you know it is an
interesting window into how far wrong
that can go in the human psyche
especially when you make it business
this whole documentary really think
calling a horrible people is not a bad
slang for it because the way they
manipulate each other's arguments the
way how each argument and their defense
just seem it's like this weird cyclical
process people are mad about you know
the way we're breeding animals animal
rights activists we're the ones breeding
these animals are on the verge of
extinction so how is what we're doing
wrong well I mean it's what you do after
they've been bred and how you're
breeding them and all these things
you're taking the emotional experience
out of what these animals must be going
through it's not just do they exist you
know it's like birthing people just to
be prisoners in a way yeah and it's easy
to forget that they also can sense and
feel your mood energy etc and they're
gonna pick up on you know abusive energy
yeah her and it's gonna affect their you
know well-being as well as their
physical state yeah
no but seriously wildly entertained so
much real-life yeah yeah in these
pockets of the world where does the rain
of the most random people can collect
all right guys
Tiger King there's other videos will
probably be checking out about them I'd
be fun to kick it off with this one
thanks WatchMojo friends together
subscribe to watchmojo.com notification
well you know if I would never got a
video up Eric horseman eric horseman is
the perfect person to shout out for this
one because the man is a vegan who has
greatly inspired my life we've had so
many discussions back and forth he was I
think the first person out our patreon
page be like dude I'm doing it I'm
committing to no more meat in my life
right now he takes care of a lot of
animals a major animal lover give me a
lot of great food options as well to
explore on this new adventure in my life
I want to thank you personally for being
an inspiration to me for taking care of
animals just like when I don't know if
you've seen this documentary or not but
in terms of the subject matter at hand
you are the one who I instantly thought
of when it came time to do a shout out
and so I love you buddy you've been
incredible to us in every area and I
hope you're staying safe in Atlanta and
I thought of you cuz half of these
people are on drunken venders and I know
how much you love those there's that
hooter sit right in on the set you would
be my favorite care
you